I just wanna break down some Justin Bieber lyrics,
because if you listen to the shit that he sings,
motherfucker is toxic as fuck.
I know you know that I made those mistakes maybe once or twice.
And by maybe once or twice, I mean maybe a couple of hundred times, okay?
He's saying it right there.
Cause I just need one more shot at second chances.
How many of us have heard that from a dude like, oh baby,
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
But hold on, let's hear more.
Is it too late now to say sorry?
Cause I'm missing more than just your body.
So he sends that you up text knowing full well,
and now he's gotta be okay,
well, missing more than just your body.
Can we just fuck one more time?
But let's see more.
And this is where we really realize how fucking toxic he is,
because he says, um,
I'll take every single piece of the blame if you want me to.
But you know, there's no innocent one in this game for two. Motherfucker,
sometimes you are the one who did wrong.
Like if you cheated on me,
how do I have to say sorry?
How am I participating in this?
That sounds like a 100% you're fucking wrong type situation. But.
And then can we both say the words and forget this?
How many times have you been in an argument with a fucking guy
and you're like
what The fuck am I saying sorry for?
But you say it just because
you gotta get the fucking conversation over with.
I know that I let you down.
Is it too late to say sorry now?
Yes, it's too fucking late to say sorry.
Yes, but you're a toxic prick that doesn't wanna hear that,
doesn't accept no for an answer and doesn't go away.
And then when the relationship starting to reach that 7 year itch time,
boom! You get her pregnant,
this shits bounce. A fail.
I feel sorry for the baby, but whatever.
Block the fucking celebrities